[Music]
the last Jedi the biggest Star Wars film
to win all fans over since Phantom
Menace yeah I definitely want review of
this film again because man the reaction
this movie got was crazy I mean don't
get me wrong every Star Wars film apart
from the first one has gotten some kind
of backlash when they first came out a
lot of people were against Empire Jedi
even the Christmas special I asked you
so I guess you can't act too shocked
that there's people that don't like this
movie I mean there's plenty of reasons
why but man man I'm just waiting for
Rian Johnson again a car accident and
some fan has them in a bed and forces
them to rewrite the script me personally
when I first saw it I absolutely loved a
lot of it and had some problems with
other parts for all I remember it being
a really good experience but I'm not
gonna lie the more and more I think back
on it the more and more problems do
arise well let's talk about the story as
well as look at the good stuff because
we're we enough this movie is kind of
divided into two it's very easy in my
opinion to point out what the good stuff
is and the bad stuff is the good stuff
right five Luke Skywalker but he has no
interest in training her in fact he even
tosses the lightsaber behind him many
fans were shocked by this an astonished
that he was so bitter and cold and
abandoned everybody kind of like they
said he did in the first film and one of
the most likeable characters did too
again I can see people getting angry
that this got in the way of the happily
ever after optimistic point of view but
as soon as you see Han and Leia don't
work out I think it's pretty clear
that's out the window I just assume this
is what Luke would be doing you would
feel like you'd have to banish himself
just like Yoda did why were people so
shocked by this like a lot of stories
about spiritual journeys Rey decides not
to leave and stays there until she's
trained while Luke technically refuses
to train or at least the traditional way
she does find out a lot of stuff by
herself
the island holds many mysterious secrets
as Rey herself also holds many
mysterious secrets including somehow
away for the force to connect both her
and kylo Ren either quite sure how
they're doing it but they're able to
talk to one another and even sometimes
bring a little bit of the environment
back
that's actually rather intriguing but
then you have the other story though
which is in my opinion the bad stuff the
resistance is on the run from the first
order and it's just kind of a really
long drawn-out chasing that I still
don't entirely get why can't one go
faster to catch up it has more power
through an even more confusing subplot
Finn and a new character named Rose have
to travel to a different planet to find
this code breaker that can break a barb
and somehow stop it but they don't come
across that code breaker they come
across another one and while that's
going on Leia seems to be out of
commission and Poe wants to know what's
going on but he's not being told for
absolutely no reason even if you were to
take out the details of this story which
do make absolutely no sense a lot of
these characters just aren't that
interesting I don't know why this really
slow chase is supposed to be suspenseful
I don't know why this really boring
casino is supposed to be interesting I
don't care why we're supposed to care
about space horses what how do we get
here the two stories kind of come to a
head in the last third where they
confront Snoke and big shock there's
betrayals and backstabbing and
lightsabers and giant machine shooting
at each other and ships flying all
around and all the usual Star Wars stuff
without getting into spoilers I think a
lot of people agree the movie should
have ended a half-hour earlier and most
people agree on the exact same spot
where it should have stopped that's not
to say the climax isn't interesting or
creative but it does go on way too long
and on top of that a lot of the
mysteries and dilemmas seem to already
be solved and most of them aren't that
satisfactory Snoke for example we never
find out about and I know a lot of
people say weights like the Emperor you
didn't really know anything about him
but the Emperor wasn't mentioned in the
first one we just thought it was Darth
Vader and even when he does come along
you just know he's the guy calling the
shots even op1 says that's kind of Darth
Vader himself that turned himself to the
dark side so fellas explained here it
said that Snoke did it well okay I don't
need much but just who was he how did he
come across this guy how did he turn him
how did he know Luke just something give
me something a line of dialogue I don't
care just a little bit but then it's
also strange because I never
nope that interesting and honestly a lot
of these mysteries I thought was just
gonna go the same usual route the Star
Wars goes like the chosen one or the
family blood or something like that but
they don't go that route which at first
I liked but then I realized they don't
really replace it with anything of
substance it's just kind of set up and
then nothing is delivered not something
different just nothing that's very odd
especially for a second movie that's
supposed to be the second act of
something you know where things are
supposed to be getting interesting
there's twists and turns that lead to
the third act but nothing's really
leading into the third movie apart from
ray and Kyle Lohse connection but it
doesn't seem like a huge cliffhanger to
see what's gonna happen with them but
okay those are the downsides the good
sides pretty much anything with ray Luke
and kylo Ren I love the shit out of I
adore all these characters I know
technically they don't even do that much
until the third act but they're just so
interesting I love hearing them talk and
I love their dialogue I can just watch
them do nothing it's so funny because
the side story has so much shit going on
but because I don't really care about
those characters I don't get into it
with them so little is going on and yet
they do it so well and so engaging and
they're so complex and I just want learn
more and more about them it also feels
like they're evolving the idea of the
force as well it always kind of seemed
like the force was one thing and in the
first three movies it seemed to evolve a
little bit you find out a few more
tricks but then it just kind of stayed
the same well unless you count blood
tests which most people don't but you
know the idea the force is around us you
lift your hand you can move stuff and
fly around sometimes shoot lightning
things like that here it seems like
people who are really in touch with the
force can kind of experiment with it and
push it in a new way at first I didn't
like that Ray wasn't taught by Luke and
yeah there's also a little bit of a Chi
with these bugs that you find later in
the film but then the more I thought
about it because she does have such a
strong connection with it she can take
it in a new direction she can kind of
recreate it reshift it redefine it it
can become something really new even
having the books I kind of like because
it gives her the basics and she can
figure out where to go from there and
how to sort of morph and shift and
experiment with it
it's the first time in a long time I got
legitimately excited for an idea in Star
Wars on top of that it's hands-down the
best-looking Star Wars film I mean okay
some of these places could have been
designed better but the way it's shot
the epic poses the way they have the Sun
the way they're silhouetted the way they
stand it all seems so gigantic it's like
an animate some of those really good
animes that seem so huge but I don't
think that's just the cinematography I
do think it's the character specifically
ray Luke and kylo Ren so looking back it
is a little bit more of a mixed bag than
perhaps I remember it is a little too
complicated a little too long and
probably explains too much and what it
does explain is not really that
satisfactory it's more leading us down
one path and then suddenly leading us
down a different one but that new path
doesn't really go anywhere but I'll
admit the stuff I do like is some of my
favorite stuff in any of the Star Wars
films it's the first time I can remember
where I was watching a Star Wars movie
and I had like butterflies in my stomach
I was afraid what was gonna happen I
didn't know what was gonna happen I was
excited for it so yeah pretty much
everything done with Luke Rey kylo Ren
and the forest I really really enjoy
some of the best I've ever seen in any
of the Star Wars flicks the stuff done
with Finn Rose the first-order Snoke and
those things I didn't think were the
worst they just weren't that good it's
nice to have it on blu-ray because that
means I can watch the best parts over
and over and skip the parts that don't
interest me and miss very little it's a
good big screen movie for the visuals
but a good disc movie to rewatch the
best parts and fast-forward the bland
ones
you